ich habe sehr viele kontakte mit
flüchtlingsfrauen migranten frauen und
selber die erfahrung als mutter von vier
kindern dass das sehr sehr schwierig ist
uns es war immer probleme da aber noch
nie war das so sichtbar wie in kona zeit
wir möchten gerne unser kinder mehr mehr
unterstützen nicht nur ausrüstung von
laptop und computer
unser kinder mehr helfen
wobei möchten sie immer wir helfen beim
lernen ist groß ich habe ein großer
botschaft für sie weil die familien
deren kinder missbildung helfen die
kinder sind zu hause die kinder
die lehrer arbeiten auf hochtouren
schulen auch die kinder vom zu hause die
eltern sind wir sind machtlos viele
familien in wattenscheid bochum
wattenscheid viele migrationsfamilien
sind einfach und alphabete die kinder
kommen und die bekommen die
unterstützung nicht da ist ja sehr sehr
sagte wir brauchen wir brauchen als
familien- oder als müttern mehr frauen
arbeit mehr familienarbeit vernetzung
mit schulen mit uli mit bildungszentrum
wir wollen gemeinsam kooperieren wir
wollen nicht gegen einander leben
sondern miteinander leben damit wir in
10 20 jahren auch von unserer zukunft
auch profitieren können die kinder sind
nun mal da die müssen unterstützt werden
nicht nur von schulen sondern auch und
familien von mutter und vater richtig
dass das also ich meine das zeigt sich
jetzt natürlich ganz schwierig da die
sie das sagen viele sind analphabeten
viele möchten ihren kindern helfen aber
können es jetzt nicht und wenn dann das
homeschooling nicht funktioniert oder
wenn man da nicht mit kommt dann ist das
schon extrem schwer deshalb kann ich
auch nur noch mal das wiederholen was er
gesagt haben wir wollen ja auch die
schulen als erstes wieder aufmachen
damit da auch was passiert man muss ja
auch sagen dass auch unsere
digitalisierung noch nicht so gut
fortgeschritten ist wie man es
eigentlich sein sollte ich glaube da
gibt es jetzt einen richtigen schub aber
werde ich wenn die eltern das nicht
können wenn die eltern die sprache nicht
können ich verstehe das ist das problem
ja die ausrüstung war ja am anfang das
problem aber die bedienung ist auch noch
ein zweites
und viele frauen sind die kamen auch die
frauen die flüchtlingsfrau kamen ja
schon mit mit trauma mit probleme mit
stress und jetzt in der ko phase ist das
hat sich das verdoppelt glauben sie ihr
leid ist viel größer geworden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren